- All right, DRock, hopefully
this is not a dick pic
and things get weird.
You know what I need from you, Mom?
I think I need more stories from you
about my entrepreneurship.
Nobody knows that more than you.
It's disheartening to know
it can never really go there,
you know what I mean?
It's DNA.
Born an entrepreneur,
born willing to look at
half glass full, half glass empty.
I mean, that's just real,
you know what I mean?
That's why I'm so thankful.
I don't think I'm special,
I think I got lucky.
And this is for a week or
two while I figure it out
are 30 to 90 second
clips from that episode
with a link to the YouTube...
like the clip is native, and then the copy
is a link to YouTube, got it?
- [Voiceover] Basically, it's the trailer
that drives them.
- Correct.
You know, truth is I didn't read books,
I didn't look up to
entrepreneurs growing up.
It's such a different era growing up
in the 80s and early 90s.
Business men and women weren't heralded
or they definitely
weren't pop culture enough
for a 14 or 17 or 22 year old to know
what the hell was going on.
We need to spend 30 to 60 days
together before I do that.
How's...
What's up, Snapchat?
It's me, Gary, but you know that.
Fire questions away, I'm gonna try
to answer a bunch later
today when I've got a moment,
so fire them now!
What?
- [DRock] I'm gonna go get coffee.
- Go ahead.
(chuckling)
No coffee!
Just making a call.
I'm fine.
Uh, I don't know.
The truth is I don't know.
I'm meeting with her within 30 days
to have, like, a real
kind of business chat, so.
- Hey, hey!
- Hey, brother.
- How's it going?
- Good to see you.
- Nice seeing you.
How's it going?
- Really enjoyed the other day.
Hello.
- Hi.
Mark Cheller.
- Mark, Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Nice to meet you.
How are you?
- Welcome.
- Thank you so much.
- I heard our teams had a good meeting.
- Yeah, we had a lot of fun.
The reason I spent time
at the boot and auction
is I was a major baseball
card collectible kid
and I used to come to
Parsippany baseball card show
on Tuesday nights at the Holiday Inn.
- Okay.
- For years, so.
- Is that still going on?
- I'm not sure.
- I had thousands of
baseball cards, oh my God.
- Did you, yeah?
- I still do.
They're just...
- What years?
- Oh, God.
From mid 60s
to mid 70s.
- Really?
- I've got tons of them.
- In good shape?
Hey, KKV.
How are you?
So, good day.
Little bit of Snapchat engagement,
be able to do that right now.
Actually, let's do one right now.
So that's good.
Starting to get into book prime time.
That's kind of cool.
All right DRock, hopefully
this is not a dick pic
and things get weird.
Let's go here.
- Gary, I love your
snaps, I love your energy.
But I still have no idea
what you actually do.
(laughing)
- I love it.
- Darling, I run, I grew a
huge wine retail business,
a store and a dot com from
three to 60 million dollars
in sales as my first chapter.
That was one.
Chellabella, and now I run
a 600 person digital agency.
I look good today, by the way.
I don't know if you'd noticed.
600 person digital agency,
think of it as Mad Men 2016.
You don't think I look good today?
- [DRock] In black, in black, yeah.
- Black always look good?
Yeah, I feel like I
look really good today.
Kyleprotechguy, let's see.
You good, or?
You want to go here, it's
probably even better, right?
Look, I understand light now, Derok.
- [DRock] Go ahead.
- What's the most effective tool I can use
to grow my, well, growing
computer repair business
in such a crowded marketplace?
There's tons of computer
repair companies out there
and it seems hard to gain traction.
- Great question.
Kyle, Google Ad Words.
It will just work.
People are trying to find that stuff.
Plus, you have to put out content.
I see your face, you can do it.
Put out little 40 second
tips on how to repair.
I'm about to give really good advice
that I want all of you
to pay attention to.
Come on, Kyle, come on.
Keep going, come on.
See, the thing that
people don't realize is
you want to teach people how to fix things
without paying you for it
because that builds up leverage.
You give up a sale in the beginning,
but you get all the sales in the end.
- I'm gonna send Gary V one Snapchat video
every single day until he
agrees to do an interview
for Supporting our Young Leaders podcast.
- Kevin, I like the hustle.
So it sounds like what you're saying is
you're gonna make a Snapchat video
to try to convince me to do a podcast
every day until I do it.
Now is going to be the
interesting part of this equation.
What's going to be interesting
is to see how much intestinal
fortitude you have,
how much patience you have, young man.
How bad do you want it?
I think media content websites
for distribution is a real compliment
to what VaynerMedia does.
What up, yo, yo, yo, hey, yo yo yo yo yo,
Kuwait in the house.
Boston, here, I'm headed to a meeting.
Detroit, loving you.
Always a big fan of Jacksonville.
Seattle, Seattle, Seattle.
I'm debating a Seattle book tour.
I just Tweeted, check it out.
I just Tweeted that I've got three dates,
the 7th, 9th, and 10th of March available
to go anywhere in the US
for bulk book buys,
looking forward to that.
But the big announcement,
why I jumped on Periscope,
is the Super8, super, the number
eight, at vaynermedia.com.
The big event on February 23, 10am to 6pm.
How many of you are
familiar with what I'm doing
on Super8?
Oh, a large amount, I love.
How many people are familiar
with what's going on on February 23?
Say yes and no.
Say yes and no, I want
all 600 of you responding.
Yes and no.
Lot of no's, good, because I haven't
really been promoting yet.
Lot of no's.
Ooh, lots of no's.
That's good.
That excites me, DRock.
I love DRock doing DailyVee 13.
A lot of no's.
Look at all these no's.
All right,
go to garyvaynerchuk.com, go to my blog,
it's just been posted.
Super8.
March, March, February
23, from 10am to 6pm,
I'm gonna go livestreaming Periscope,
Meerkat, Facebook live,
for eight hours, right?
- [DRock] Yep, eight hours.
- 10:00 to 6:00.
To buy eight copies, and then email them
to super8@vaynermedia.com.
I will draw a receipt
and one of you will get
the thousand book deal,
which is coming to New York on my dime.
I will fly you to New York, or drive you,
or you will walk over to VaynerMedia,
and we will spend one hour together
doing whatever you want,
focusing on building out your business,
an interview, shooting
the shit about technology.
One hour for me to consult or bring you
the most possible value ever, and I think
it's going to be unbelievable.
I like to have some ideas on like,
business development aspects, mainly,
less so about the "I'll take it."
All right, guys.
- No cherries, no hazlenuts,
dressing on the side, add shrimp.
- Hi Thera.
- Hi, hi.
(chuckling)
(calm music)
- [Gary] I'd much rather do
a little bit of half and half
instead of skim, I'm doing neither now.
I'm on all skim now.
- I love it.
- Which sucks, I love half and half.
Even in my prime, that six months,
I only did skim like 23% of the time.
I love half and half, I don't
even like coffee with skim.
I like it with half and half,
and lots of half and half,
like, tons of half and half.
- Yeah, that's not good.
- I know.
I'm super fucking foc--
- A little half and half.
- No, no.
I'm going little skim.
- I love it.
- I'm in such a mindset right now
that I want to just go black.
- Should we do black coffee?
- Yeah.
No.
I still need a little skim.
It's coming.
Bang!
- How's it going, Gary?
- Good, how are you?
- Very good.
- Good.
- It's Paul.
- Paul.
- The hitchiking guy.
- Yes, oh, you're here!
- How are you man?
- Very good, man, good to meet you.
- Congrats.
Congrats for making it.
- Yeah, I was here at 10.
You weren't here, so I just came back.
- Come and hung out?
- It's so good to be here,
like seeing people real, like--
- It's real.
- Yeah, it's fun.
- Chill, can you give me
two seconds to get settled?
Where's Demayo?
- He was just here.
- Hey, DRock.
He was here.
(chuckling)
- What's up, DRock?
- I did it, I made it.
I made it again.
It's been a while, I missed you all.
(calm music)
(loud ringing)
- We're not saying anything?
Yeah, hold on, let's go.
- Yeah, I'm keeping your phone with me
because it needs to get to
100, because you're gone.
- Okay.
Let him know.
- I'm Jed.
- Jed.
- Good to meet you, this is Allen.
- Allen.
- Good to meet you.
- Real pleasure.
- So yeah, we're just--
- Right here?
- Yeah.
- No mic?
Can you help me?
I'm bad at this.
- Oh yeah.
- You're gonna be double lights.
- Double light.
So is that like a double rainbow, or?
- [Voiceover] That's amazing.
- This is a rarity.
- You like that one?
How about, let's have Andrew--
- Wait, are we in a vlog?
- Yeah, you're gonna be in the vlog.
- Nice, that's crazy.
- Make sure your levels
are on the outside.
- You good?
It's very hard to calculate the ROI
when you're not in control of
how the whole thing gets sold
or if you're doing other activities.
Let me explain.
If you're running Snapchat
as Sour Patch Kids
or a car company or a tennis ball company,
if you're also doing radio and television
and your product is being sold at 7-11
and Walmart, you just really don't know.
Most of these companies
don't shut off everything
and just do Snapchat and
then see what happens.
"Oh, we have 28 weeks of consistent sales.
"Now it's gone down 8%,
Snapchat didn't work."
Or "Now we've gone up 15%, it worked."
- Like, we're behind and ready.
- What am I doing next?
- AJ needs you for 30 seconds.
- Yup.
What do you think about us
moving to 12 for a little while?
- Me and you?
- Yeah.
And then moving our infrastructure.
- Sure.
- Play with that.
- Yeah.
- In your head.
I want to do that.
I personally want to do it.
- You want you and I--
- Let me start over.
Let me get my actual KPI.
I want to be on 12 with you.
- So I watched the latest DailyVee.
- Okay.
- You talked about the fact
that you don't like dogs.
- Yes.
- Which I'm fine with.
I'm gonna say on cam.
- That was me hyperbolizing
on how much I love people.
I'm not confused that dogs are
nice and that oxygen matters
and that Mother Nature's
a good thing, like
I'm not lost to those things.
- Okay, of course not.
- I was laughing at the
comments last night,
like, you know, "Dude,
without Mother Nature
"there'd be no oxygen!
"You'd be dead!
"Dude, if there was no trees,
you couldn't print paper
"and you wouldn't be able
to sell, #AskGaryVee books!"
And I'm like, "Guys.
"I'm joking.
"The main point is I love humans."
- I'm in the same camp.
I just thought it was funny
because when I heard that,
first of all, I connect the two.
(Gary's chuckling drowns out speaking)
And I always feel like such
a jerk when I say that.
- Yeah, well I try to do
it for people like us.
- I appreciate it.
I was like, "We need our own community."
- Yeah, we need our community.
- Gary.
- How are you?
- Great, it's a pleasure to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- You've got a hell of an operation here.
Very impressive.
- Thank you, brother.
- Instead of millions, I'm focused now on
- [Both] Hundreds of millions.
- Or billions.
- Sure.
- And I've always felt that I've
had a destiny to do something greater.
- Good.
- Not necessarily be famous.
- I get it.
- But to do something more substantial
and then--
- So, given that I have
to do a public speech,
what's the main question,
what should you do next?
- I think, really, I
came to try to just get
some energy from you.
- Got it.
- I don't have a--
- Here's the real energy.
- I think you need to put
out, if you want to do
hundreds of millions and
you're willing to be out there,
which is all the clear
indications you are,
you have to put out content.
You've got to put out content every day.
- So my question to that is,
as I've studied and as
I'm sure you've seen,
a lot of the content,
it's the same content
but done in a different
way or a different spin.
Same stuff, but done differently.
- Of course.
- So is that the idea?
- Look, I'll give you a better
piece of advice than that.
I would do you.
- Yeah.
- Like, I even said the
other day on DailyVee
I don't want to be a motivational speaker.
I'm motivating. I'm high energy.
But I continue at all costs
to not consume any of it,
because then it's not me.
- Correct.
- What I am is motivational,
but I'm building
for 600 fucking people working here.
I'm like fucking up Madison Avenue
because I'm revolutionizing
the advertising world
in agency form, the way
I did for liquor stores.
I didn't need those guys
to build a wine library,
I did me.
Now it sounds like you've consumed some,
and that was just fine.
My biggest piece of
advice is to unwind that
and be you.
But I think you just have
to go honest as fuck,
and I will tell you the number one thing
that scares the fuck out of me.
Nice watches and Ferraris.
Here's what I mean.
Do not sell these people bullshit.
- [Man] It's got to be real,
it's got to be valuable.
- [Gary] Because you'll make money,
but your grandkids are
gonna think you were a dick.
- [Man] Understood.
- [Gary] You built an
actual fucking business.
You're not a fucking self-help coach
that only sells info products.
It comes down to very
simple things, which is
do not get caught up in taking
a fucking pretty picture,
like on a vacation, on a
fucking boat, on Instagram,
and selling these people bullshit.
Everybody's doing that.
- [Man] It's everywhere you go.
- [Gary] You built a business.
That's what you pound on.
And if you happen to be
motivating and charismatic...
- [Man] All the better.
- [Gary] All the fucking better.
But there's plenty of people
that none of these people
have ever heard of making bank,
and they're not charismatic,
and they're not clever,
and they're not cute or interesting.
They're just fucking making
hundreds of millions of dollars
running businesses.
But the further you're willing to go
down the truth barrel,
the more you're gonna win.
I think all I can tell you is,
if you get anything out of me,
is all the hyperbole in
the bullshit and drama
and excitement and energy
and accolades that I have,
the thing I feel best about,
and you know my dad, too,
better than you know me,
is there's truth behind it.
I love that, because
I know a lot of people
that there are isn't.
And don't be one of those
people, it's too easy.
You've made, that's,
my man, my man, my man.
Those are hundreds of
thousands and millions
for the couple people that are
the best at being bullshit,
you've already made that.
The fuck are you gonna play in
hundreds of thousands of millions.
You want something real?
You want something fucking real?
Play for tens and hundreds.
That only comes in real shit.
Don't sell fucking shit that's not true.
There's no fucking secret.
The secret isn't real, like, "I hope,"
that's not real, it's fucking work.
Like you know how you build
a business in 20 years?
You fucking work your face off!
Like you woke up at
six and went to the job
and it snowed, but you gotta show up,
because if that person
said you were a dick,
then this organization
wasn't gonna use you.
Talk about accountability.
Talk about when there's only three or four
major builders in New Jersey,
but you can't fuck up, ever,
because once your
reputation's shit, you're out.
There's a million people that
want to fucking insulate.
Got it?
- [Man] Yeah.
You're the man, man, I appreciate it.
- Take care.
- Very much.
- Stay well.
I wish you well, my pleasure.
How long is it gonna be?
Because I want it when I
make when I sell it, yup.
Or 2:13, or you know what I mean?
Don't even let it be close, be like
07 or 13, something like that.
Thank you.
- My friend.
- Good to meet you, man.
- Tell me all about yourself.
- I'm from Germany.
- Yes, that I know.
I saw on some social media stuff
it seemed like you did some TV interviews.
- I did a lot of TV interviews.
- I recently ran into a guy from Germany,
he's a student, and he began
a nearly 3,000 mile long
American adventure without
a dime in his pocket.
- He's depending entirely
on the kindness of others.
His goal is to make it to New York City.
- And in New York City I want
to go to on the live show,
on the web show of Gary Vaynerchuk
on the #AskGaryVee show,
that's the main goal.
- This is everything that
you're taking with you?
- Right, that's all I'm taking,
and this is basically
my ticket to New York.
- So what you got to talk about now?
The experience?
- Yeah--
- Amazing, right?
- Yes, it is.
- You should write a book.
- Actually, I think about going through
(ambiance drowns out speaker)
- Tell me more about yourself.
You got siblings?
- Yeah, I've got two sisters.
- Very nice.
- I've got a business in Germany
where I'm doing furniture,
I'm doing this with a friend right now.
- Good for you.
- He actually introduced me to you,
and I thought you are weird.
(both laughing)
- I am weird!
- And I showed you the house
that I'm staying at,
I showed you yesterday.
It's like, I can't stand this guy.
- I get it.
- It's too much energy
(ambiance drowns out speaker)
- I totally get it.
- Take some time to get used to it.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm not confused
that the energy gets to people.
Listen, any time you do a business
that goes from zero to something,
it's amazingly well.
And I've been working
every day for 20 years.
You know what I mean?
- It's fucking amazing.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't ever say,
I never say to somebody, the
first year I met Facebook
they were losing money.
They did amazingly well, so, you know.
Yeah, I think it's incredible.
Good for you.
Oh, look at Dennis!
Did you know Dennis was going to be here?
- No.
- Dennis!
- Haha!
- Oh, Gary!
- How are ya?
How are you?
- Great, Gary.
- How you doing?
- Good, you are you?
- Look at this!
You get to be on DailyVee, too.
- Again?
- Again!
It's great to see you.
- Good to see you too, Gary.
- Really good?
- Yeah, really good stuff here.
- I'll catch up with you.
All right man, talk to you, buh bye.
And that's why we do it.
Dennis!
Dog!
- It's funny, one of your first business
was selling flowers, right?
- Yes.
- Same with me.
- Is that right?
- When I was like five,
my grandpa was selling
trees chip, and to get
the ground nutrition,
the earth, they plant sunflowers.
And we sold sunflowers.
- Yes, I love it.
I love it, it's the hustlers mentality.
It's the same thing.
You've got to tell the
person you stayed with
that couldn't stand me that
I want to be his friend.
- I'll tell him.
- Yeah.
All right, I have to make a quick call.
Give me, excuse me for one sec.
It's the dude who hitch-hiked
across the country.
- Oh, really?
I know about you.
- I'm sorry, I'm Audrey Puente from Fox 5.
- I know who you are.
- Oh my gosh.
- Good to see you.
Is it gonna snow in Boston tomorrow?
- Tomorrow, yes.
It is gonna snow.
Can I get a picture with you?
- Yes, of course.
(gasps)
- I can't believe what I look like!
(chuckles)
It looks terrible!
I can't believe you know
who I am looking like this.
Bobby, this is Gary.
By the way, this is my son Mateo.
- Hey Mateo, how are you?
- I'm good.
- Oh my gosh.
- He's got the skills.
- You start them young,
you start them young.
- Real pleasure to see you.
Nice to meet you, take care.
- DRock, my man.
Okay, I could do this.
This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
#AskGaryVee--
- No, DailyVee.
- The DailyVee.
- You haven't watched the DailyVee?
- I've watched the DailyVee.
I'm on Snap, I'm in there with you.
- All right, all right.
- Jack threads in the cut right here.
- Yes.
- Kid is repping.
- How are you, brother?
Good to see you.
Ready?
- What's going on?
- Let's go inside.
- Yes.
- Barry Vaynersuk was the best video
in my entire--
- You talk about the effort
that was put into that video?
- You nailed it.
As a matter of fact, you know what, DRock?
Show a clip of Barry Vaynersuk.
- Gary's alter ego is Barry Vaynersuk.
Honestly, everybody is so
much hustle these days.
They want to start the
next billion dollar app,
Uber, Airbnb, Facebook.
It's crazy.
It's pathetic.
I'm here to tell you it's
impossible to be successful.
If you don't like what you're doing,
continue doing it.
Stop trying to own shit.
Please stop.
- [Gary] Guys, this is Ryan Alovis.
Say hi, Lolo.
- Hello everybody, my name is Ryan Alovis.
Can I own your shit?
- [Gary] Yes, this man is
gonna be huge on Snapchat.
I've literally never seen this before.
Lolo, your stories!
- I'm a doody bowl, look
at this fucking movie.
- Wow.
I've never seen it.
It's so rare.
I'm a serious kid, this is my friend Ryan.
And he reminds me so much of me,
like he's a real businessman,
but he's so crazy entertaining.
That's why I did that.
This is my man Derrik, my new friend.
I'm about to convince
him to get on Snapchat.
Right?
- I'm going, I'm in.
(chill music)
- Gary V!
- Hey, brother.
- What's up man, long time.
- Good to see ya, how are you?
- Good to see you too.
- I just Tweeted about Super8.
Who's in?
New York City, baby.
More meetings.
Meeting after meeting, meeting
meeting meeting meeting!
Meeting!
Meeting, motherfucker.
Great adventures.
Power meeting.
Fucking working.
We're working.